al salir el sol sobre la disputada
Península de crimea una enorme columna
de humo se elevó por encima del puente
de kerch El único paso entre la crimea
ocupada y la Rusia continental el comité
Nacional antiterrorista de Moscú informó
sobre el incidente
según información preliminar esta mañana
un camión explotó en la carretera del
puente de crimea desde la Península de
tamán lo que condujo a la ignición de
siete tanques de combustibles de un tren
que viajaba hacia la Península de
crimeable
Rusia mantenía que el puente era seguro
a pesar de los combates en Ucrania Pero
había amenazado a kiev con represalias
si este era atacado el puente ha sido un
enlace de transporte clave para llevar
equipo militar y soldados rusos a
Ucrania también es simbólico cuando
Vladimir Putin inauguró el puente en
mayo de 2018 intensificó La anexión
ilegal de la Península por parte de
Moscú
desde la época de los zares la gente
soñaba con construir este puente por fin
gracias a su trabajo a su talento este
proyecto este milagro Se ha producido
Muchas gracias
15 mil trabajadores e ingenieros se
apresuraron a terminar el controvertido
proyecto de 3000 millones de euros en un
tiempo récord menos de 4 años después de
que Putin declarara crimea como parte de
Rusia una anexión a ojos de la comunidad
internacional pero una reunificación
territorial largamente esperada por el
presidente ruso un par de horas después
de que se produjera el incendio el
sábado por la mañana un asesor
presidencial ucraniano publicó en
Twitter todo lo ilegal debe ser
destruido todos los robado debe ser de
vuelta a Ucrania todo lo ocupado por
Rusia debe ser expulsado Vladimir Putin
ha ordenado que una comisión Investiga
la explosión